a Chancellor has been promoting
innovation in the UK financial
technology sector in a major speech
today but for all online businesses one
word is under the spotlight like never
before data it's extraordinarily
valuable but it faces that have a
greater scrutiny so what should we
expect from business when it comes to
our personal information one of those
listening sir philip hammond earlier was
method chromakey so chief executive of
go company joins me now matthew for you
could see here could even a companies
like yours doing enough to protect
consumers from their data being
mistreated yeah what i can talk about is
what we do we started up about twelve
years ago by five entrepreneurs in south
wales and right from the very start they
were regulated by the FCA we're still
regulated by their say and I'm
personally out and so we take our
relationship and our consumers data very
seriously because we're consumers give
us permission to use that data we'll
process their data to give them a
service it's quite a simple relationship
we allow we take that information we
work up a series of quotes for them and
then choose what they want to do and
then move on where they give us
permission will and go back to them
later and say you know your policies up
for renewal would you like to do
something else it's quite simple and we
obviously take that very very seriously
it spin part of our thoughts if you like
the last twelve years
yeah the competition markets Authority
does have a bit of an issue with price
comparison website so it doesn't mean
it's quite wary that data is being
mistreated I mean there was a
competition Markets Authority study last
year and they they broadly said we are a
first force for good we've saved
certainly I can talk for us we've said
billions of pounds for UK consumers over
the last 12 years you know we feel we
have a very transparent certainty for
our business we have a very transparent
way of doing business we we don't take
advertising money on our site we don't
have paid for promotional placement for
companies to push themselves up
algorithms are very simple it's what you
see is what you get now I can only talk
for what we do but for us that you're
going back to that East off those five
people on the kitchen table 12 years ago
that was basically back to that but do
you think that price comparison sites
need to do more to demonstrate to
customers that their data is being used
responsibly how do you convince people
that mean clearly
post the Facebook scandal there is going
to
scepticism you know again I can talk to
what we do and and we we constantly
remind our consumers of the trust we're
trying to build with them what happens
environmentally whether other companies
may or may not help that but we try to
remind our our customers that we're
there basically to save them time and
money it's quite a simple concept
instead of crates of phone around 15
insurance they get to do one process and
they get a series of results but it is a
constant battle there are a lot there's
lots of noise in the marketplace and
therefore we have to say that quite
seriously do you worry though that post
Facebook there is going to be greater
regulation coming down the line on
businesses like yours well I I think you
know I can't comment on what the
regulator's will do I think what what's
happened recently in this last week
could be well be a seminal moment for
other companies they have quite a
complex relationship with consumers in a
social network environment we have a
quite a simple one and our aim is to try
and keep that relationship simple and
quite transparent and I think by doing
that certainly I think we have a strong
possibility to keep that relationship
with the consumer strong yes I mean
clearly Facebook have handled this
situation absolutely dreadfully
suspicions of them is probably an
all-time high do you worry that the
entire industry is going to get tired
with that rush I think we're not the
same industry that's all I would say
we're not even remotely the same model
the fact we use software I think he's
about the only the only similarity but
you know it's built on data we you know
we do we do use data and the way we use
that data to provide a service though
again I'll come back to is quite simple
and I think the complexity of some of
the large global companies the way they
operate how they're structured even and
how they do business around the world
makes it rather opaque for people to see
how they operate and what they do we try
and keep that it's quite simple so I'll
just keep come back to that simplicity
if you keep it simple then I think
you've got a great opportunity to win
business and to keep that keep that
going over the years